ist das geil ist das geil ich kann ich
will kann in den weltraum fliegen
schaut euch das ab
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem etwas speziellen video zu einem
besonderen video und zwar wisst ihr
sicherlich wir haben vor einigen tagen
die 10.000 autos geknackt und bis dahin
oder seitdem bin ich euch noch wegen zu
bahnhof übrigens ein dankeschön schuldig
geblieben das soll jetzt aufhören
hiermit möchte ich jetzt mal ja so ein
kleines dankeschön präsentieren und zwar
seht ihr die überraschung direkt die
überraschung ist dieses wunderschöne
geile texture pack schaut euch diesen
himmel an diese waffen aber egal ich bin
beim bahnhof ich habe auch waffen für
dich wenn du mir eine waffe gefunden das
texture pack bei der liebe riesige macht
und ihr könnt das auch haben
ihr kennt das spielen in den planungen
buchhalter alter an ihre gold um mein
gott oh mein gott bist du ja bei dem
ganzen menschenmasse jahre alte halter
hatte ich damals hatte ich damals ja ich
habe ein gerät gerade jetzt fragen
welche von den bis zu der mit der
diamant ja da bin ich da bin ich da bin
ich da bin alles klar so werde überleben
team skoda team ein logo richtig scheiße
so okay jetzt mal durchatmen ist ja
schaut euch das an ich will euch in
dieser runde so ein bisschen das texture
pack vorstellen
das hat mir der liebe riesige macht der
link zum download ist in der
beschreibung für alle die das pack auch
mal selbst spielen wollen und ich sage
ich hoffe nur es wird nach beenden der
nach themen ist so geil in diesem text
effekt auch der himmel bei tages ich das
richtig gut
die extra die wolken ausgestellt weil es
aber so schön aussieht richtig
fotorealistisch einfach ein traum
und 10.000 rasseln und naja ich hab es
auch hart gefeiert die abzeichnet
bekommen auf instagram twitter da haben
wir wirklich krass gefreut dass ich dann
auch diesen youtuber status die aufgabe
hatte was wirklich auf ewig lange schon
so vor augen schwebt
lebst du ja ich überlebt das internet
was wenn jetzt kein anderer als da
obwohl du kannst mir kurz vor das
feuerzeug trocken ja da ich habe dich
und den bogen so und den bogen für bogen
welchen booking tool so ich zeige das
einfach mal hier guck ich war dieses
feuerzeuge an das ist richtig lustig das
ist schon krass verspielt das texture
pack ist das ist vorzüglich irgendwie so
ein zippo richtig cool die farbe ist
leader ich feiere das es ist einfach ein
feedback also für alle die irgendwie
mega nüchtern spielen wollen ist es
nicht das richtige aber ich fand's
megacool ali claudi silverstone und ein
schwert falls das nicht gezeigt und sie
haben wir den bogen mit mit coach der
fall verändert die farbe
da kann man das erkennen hier die
schwerter also erstmal hier die die
racks aber die schwerter sind noch viel
schöner schaut euch das an richtig cool
ich weiß gar nicht wie viele milliarden
pixeln zum schwert stecken
wenn wir richtig schöne teile finde ich
echt geil und ja ich würde sagen was
gibt es denn noch vorzustellen wird
seitlich spielen mal die runde und rang
sehr gerne sieht auch cool aussieht hier
so eine richtig coole schimmerndes lila
auch sehr sehr geil hier kandidaten nach
den den hirnen beim schiefen zu sehen
dass ihr euch viele auch wichtig hier ja
der bürger habe ich schon gespannt haben
gezeigt und wird spielen
warum und schauen sie was passiert ja
wie gesagt teams sowie games hierauf sg
vierter mit dem logo und der ist hier
auch in der beschreibung
ihr könnt euch gerne das pack
herunterladen das wird von meinem jahr
vom designer von riefen die verfügung
gestellt können dass ein schöner
vorbeischauen wenn ihr wollt dann seid
doch so freundlich und last seinem video
man leichter und ihm vielleicht wäre es
gut für etwas er so macht
und ja für mich auch schon ein bisschen
auf das pack ich will unbedingt diesen
himmel sehen wie sich das so vorstellen
bekommen die lobby und einfach auf
der nachthimmel ist so geil
wir müssen auf jeden fall die runden aus
zürich will unbedingt den nachthimmel
zeigen wollen unbedingt dass es so schön
falls ihr euch jetzt nicht zeigen kann
leute holt euch selbst das pack spielt
mal ist echt geil und ist es gar nicht
weiß gar nicht ob sie so mega intensiv
ist also weiß intensiv läuft genauso gut
wie das 128 er zwecks was atomkraft
davor für mich gemacht hat und ich finde
die waffen sogar l so viele sachen zu
tun dass man zueinander stehen die
meisten
du siehst du die leute ich muss ich
natürlich meinen dank aussprechen dafür
dass dass ihr mich unterstützt habt
jetzt über die ganze zeit das ist ich
habe beim achten dezember ich mein
erstes die hochgeladen oder am achten
dezember die kahler stellt kommt sie zum
hange ja ich bin ja ich hab da noch ne
kiste gluten okay ich warte hier
und ja es ist bald einfach auch schon
wieder ein jahr und auch eine mega
krasse zeit ganz leute die man kennen
gelernt hat ja einfach mega cool jetzt
die video days waren echt der hammer das
war auch so geil da hat richtig viel
spaß gemacht und womöglich wird es
natürlich alles von euch aber es ist
einfach wirklich so man selbst steckt
unglaublich viel arbeit rein das ist so
aber andererseits bringt es einem alles
nichts wenn man keine leute hat die das
was man macht anschauen sich freuen wenn
man das sieht und ich glaube auch gerade
das ich dann im sommer angefangen habe
jeden tag video zu machen hat schon so
ja sowieso die bindung zwischen euch
also meinen abonnenten und mir noch
verstärkt weil einfach youtube dann noch
ein wichtiger part noch wichtiger rat
meines lebens war und ich dann jeden tag
wirklich ein video gemacht habe es war
mit ausnahme von gestern wo ich jetzt
einfach nicht konnte habe ich gearbeitet
und dann abends
weiter ok heute geht es mal nicht aber
ich versuche nach im rahmen meiner
möglichkeiten jeden tag gutes video für
euch zu machen
und ja es scheint ja auch zu gefallen
das freut mich natürlich für so eine
süße ansprache meinen daumen nach oben
bei dem ja ich habe jetzt einfach mal so
raus gequasselt was mir alles so auf dem
herzen lag das weiterhin zwei langen
messer vor der monolog sind auch nicht
aufgefallen ja am besten noch so
traurige musik und mit unserem eine
party musik
wir sollten noch am gleichen tag nicht
die ganzen leute alter sind alle weg wir
sind jetzt wie waren beim kanada wo
immer die kämpfe wie man ist beim
bahnhof dabei immer gekämpft aber am
anfang
das ist eine ente ist glaube ich muss
kurz vorm demonstrieren können von
rechts ab der kassiererin laufen hat er
die jedoch gar tipps gegeben oder gar
nicht die ganze zeit da unsere geben
nachhilfe geben oder irre ich gehe
einfach aber wir konnten gar nicht mehr
hat mir noch jetzt gegeben durch dich
durch schon heute bist verwirrt leute in
meinem kopf in rüstung für dich da weil
gestern doch dann eine etwas längere
nachbar war glaube ich 5 zu hause oder
youtube die leisten und ab und ab dann
bis um halb sechs noch geschnitten
geschaut dann ist natürlich ein bisschen
verballert am nächsten tag egal wie lang
und schläft treibt wenn man auch nicht
ewig schlafen kann weil ich jetzt zwölf
leute wieder mit noch einiges für die
uni machen muss und so weiter und so
fort
deswegen bin ich heute jetzt nicht auf
dem zenit meiner fähigkeiten ich habe
heute vormittag die krassesten runden
gerissen
ab dann acht leute pro runde gequält
oder so ich weiß nicht ob jemand dabei
war aufgenommen weil es dann nicht ganz
so krass ich habe mich einfach an meinen
rechner gesetzlichen gespielt und dann
so etwas habe ich auch manchmal wenn man
es dann mit kommentieren probiert tote
hose durch dazu stöpsel stürzten ganz
ein echt nicht so gut konzentrieren das
ist wirklich so da ist eine art zu wenig
für mich da und da unten steht dann noch
einen bogen
von anderer seite auch im blickpunkt zu
rücken
was mich an die sind auf jeden fall auch
ein team der erste brände
ja die probleme den anderen noch
anzuzünden
naja ich wieder weg er hat mich noch
eingezeichnet schade
den habe ich noch eingeschlossen das
zeug lebst du
laut abdrehen ich muss auf drängen aber
ich würde ich hab's überlebt betrachten
ist gut
ganz schön spannend gerade hatte ich
kann mich opfer angezündet ja ja noch
zwei herzen verbeugte nicht so kalt ich
habe zwei herzen
naja leute heute ging es ja auch nicht
so dass ich irgendwie das absolute in
dieser runde sogar einfach darum euch
das textfeld zu zeigen es wird dunkel es
wird dunkel
ich sitz ja ich flieg mahlow äußerst
klein ist das geil ich kann ich will
keine in den weltraum fliegen
schaut euch das an dieses texture pack
wunderschön mit einem hohen gott oh mein
gott ich hab's technisch gesehen heute
ist so geil ich weil es so unfassbar
und er soll erwischt das war nicht
unsere ski runter aber dieses textes ist
ob lancaster argument ist auch haben
wollt danke nochmal für die ganze
unterstützung und wir sind im nächsten
video wieder
sorry ich bin halt voll im wind wir
können leichter lassen sich gefallen hat
ihr wisst ihr wie es läuft bis dahin
jacob ist eine beschreibung horse ranch